no
[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 og en español
la amazonía ese vasto territorio que se
encuentra en américa del sur está
amenazada de muerte
la acción de empresas extractivas y la
inacción y complicidad del gobierno que
dirige el presidente bolsonaro en brasil
han causado daños irreversibles a ese
vasto territorio pulmón de la humanidad
al mismo tiempo la llegada de la
pandemia está afectando a la población
local los meridianos que se encuentran
en ese territorio y amenazan su vida
precisamente para hablar de este tema
saludamos aquí en nuestro estudio a
quien es director del centro nacional de
investigaciones sociales especialistas
de la amazonía ha trabajado en ese
territorio desde hace 37 años
estefan roston bienvenido a esta escala
en parís es usted también autor del
libro que se llama amazonía la
arqueología de mujeres muchas gracias
por acompañarnos buenos días
la comida es una vez se ha ensañado con
la población brasileña es el territorio
de américa latina' más afectado por la
pandemia de la polis 19 y dentro de esto
está fundamentalmente
a mi gran diana la población que habita
en la amazonía que usted considera está
sufriendo una situación similar a la que
se vivió hace 500 años con la llegada de
los conquistadores europeos si más o
menos ese es el problema recibieron otra
vez una enfermedad una pandemia saliendo
de afuera y que llega con occidentales y
no tienen actualmente genes para
defenderse tanto como las poblaciones
occidentales con las enfermedades
tuvieron revuelo sarampión bueno muchas
gripes durante la conquista hace 500
años
y ahora lo que vemos es que hay dos
veces más muertos en las poblaciones
indígenas de las américas el mismo caso
en eeuu donde no se habla tanto desde
ese tema pero también en eeuu las
indígenas no tienen protección no tienen
acceso a los hospitales
me acuerdo de hace un año porque llegó
muy temprano a las 19 en la amazonía muy
temprano hace en el mes de marzo del
2005 y a veces en los hospitales no
tenían como recibir toda la gente en lo
que si bien los indígenas así que
tuvieron que reaccionar de otra manera
porque han visto que no podían contar
con los europeos los occidentales en su
propio país no es el presidente
bolsonaro se dice ha sido el que más ha
liberalizado la acción de las empresas
extractivas en la amazonía con las
consecuencias que esto trae extracción
de madera de metales preciosos contamos
acción de aguas de suelos etcétera y al
mismo tiempo esto que es llamado por
algunos el pulmón del mundo parece que
hoy en día no logra reponer lo que eran
los recursos propios para regenerarse
que nos puedes decir a este propósito es
que un pulmón es un pozo para el carbón
o un pozo que retiene el carbono
absorbe el y lo tiene así me ha
mantenido sacando con la deforestación
la superficie de esa selva se reduce se
ha reducido de casi 20 por ciento
durante los últimos
40 años y por supuesto con consecuencia
que no tiene las mismas capacidad de
retener el cabo documento para dar un
solo ejemplo una sola cifra que me
parece
muy discutida entre 2002 2018 la selva
amazónica ha perdido 500.000 kilómetros
kilómetros cuadrados es dice la
superficie de españa ha desaparecido de
la amazonía es enorme y estos impactos
de esta gestión o ausencia de gestión
más bien es problemática
para la planeta porque las consecuencias
son climáticas impactan a todo todo el
globo hay que recordar simplemente que
la extensión de la amazonía es
equivalente al conjunto de los países de
la unión europea todos sumados en
superficie gigantesca el hecho que usted
menciona que precisamente se pierde el
territorio de españa es una cosa más que
inquietante a este propósito eso
significa pérdida de diversidad
biológica y sobre todo agotamiento de
tierras y la posibilidad de que vuelvan
a emerger que vuelvan a surgir esos
microbios bacterias enterrados desde
hace miles de años en una región que
hasta ahora más o menos ha estado
relativamente intacta hay que acordarse
que las primeras pandemias salieron de
áfrica tropical
como el vih la sal las segundas vinieron
del sudoeste de asia asia y yo me temo
que las próximas próximas buena serie de
la amazonía porque poner en contacto
animales
bacterias que nunca fueron en contacto
con el humano provoca consecuencias que
no conocemos estafa usted
en un texto que publicó recientemente
decía imaginaba lo que habrían hecho las
poblaciones locales si esta pandemia
hubiese llegado allí hace 500 300 ó 200
años poco importa háblenos de esto
porque es bastante interesante la
reflexión que hace este propósito usted
es hay que saber que la amazonía de hace
mil años no era la misma que la de hoy
probablemente hubo pandemias porque la
gente viviendo en este medio tuvo
contactos tal vez cuando con bacterias
antes y la reacción sobre todo la
difusión de esas enfermedades a la época
estaban muy rápidas porque había todo
toda una red de caminos entre los
pueblos y de contactos hay que pensarla
la amazonía precolombina como una
hoguera donde la gente se va por todos
lados y permanente permanente por eso
que la conquista fue tan desastrosa en
la amazonía porque a veces las
enfermedades europeas llegaron antes de
los blancos porque los indígenas que
estaban enfermos se iban de viaje a
contactar a otros pueblos
hay algunas crónicas libros de la época
que explican que los conquistadores
llegaban y todo todo todo el pueblo
estaba muerto por enfermedades europeas
sin conocer a los blancos
seguramente hace mil años hubo también
ese tipo de enfermedad y la reacción es
la misma que hoy la reacción que
hubieran hecho cerrando los pasajes
cerrando el contacto como hacen ahora le
impiden a la gente delega a sus pueblos
buscando medicinas con las plantas hay
que acordarse que los samanes la
medicina indígena de las nacionales muy
las fuentes
casi 40 mil especies de plantas hay que
poner escolar y también contactos con
los espíritus invisibles de la célula
los no humanos para entender consejos a
salvar su mundo en esta lógica en esta
filosofía esta manera de interpretar lo
que pudieron haber hecho los indígenas
en aquel entonces la población
originaria y lo que podrían hacer hoy
usted dice lo siguiente dada la
situación que se vive en la amazonía
tal vez asistimos de manera impotente a
un nuevo etnocidio la campaña ha
acompañado esta vez y un ecocidio
irremediable
usted de alguna manera acusa
o señala al presidente bolsonaro como
responsable y un etnocidio y por
supuesto el galón y el famoso jefe
indígena de basil ha atacado
en la corte internacional persona golpe
mata
a los indígenas y de todos modos nos
dice el bolsón ador el mismo que la
selva tiene que la plata que que no sabe
de nada reproductiva entre comillas sí y
tiene una visión totalmente al contrario
de la gente que vive en la amazonía y si
quiere ganar con la selva por utilizar
una expresión bastante despectiva
incluso con respecto a lo que son la
parte arqueológica
el presidente bolsonaro no refiriéndose
perdón por la expresión a la caca de los
indígenas que nos vamos a preocupar por
esto sí sí eso ha dicho en una reunión
es decir que no tiene ningún interés por
el pasado de su propio país
a mí me temo que los años de bolsa van a
dejar cicatrices por mucho tiempo en el
vacío
hay que ver cómo era después de desde
los años 2000 el país el brasil ha
subido de manera increíble del punto de
una vida para proteger la mente lengua
en contra de mico y en la amazonía
todo se fue al suelo en una sola un solo
gobierno unos cuantos años
vamos a hablar ahora si usted me lo
permite de una manera muy rápida de su
libro amazonía la arqueología de jefe
porque este título
viene de 35 años trabajando en la
amazonía y un día me di cuenta que que
finalmente yo conocí a muchas colegas
eran mujeres
y yo pensé que por placer yo no me
sacaba ellas en reales porque son más
numerosas que los hombres es el único
lugar en la planeta donde hay más
mujeres en la arqueología que hombres
hay dos veces más mujeres y a pesar de
eso son citadas en las producciones
científicas dos veces menos es decir que
no se conoce su trabajo es siempre la
gente cita a los hombres y no a las
mujeres me pareció súper me gustó y yo
quise hacer un enfoque sobre el trabajo
de estos investigadores mira somos dos
hombres que hablan otra vez de mujeres
sin duda lo reconozco la próxima vez
trataremos de que sea una colega que
entreviste porque hay que decir que
produce una cantidad de libros
impresionantes decimos con 37 años de
estar investigando en la amazonía y pues
está anunciado ya su próximo libro cuál
será el título del próximo libro que
esté pública
se va a llamar la selva virgen de amazon
al no existe y es más sobre la
deforestación y el manejo de la selva
por los indígenas de una parte y por los
occidentales por otra parte y una
comparación de este manejo de la selva
que es opuesto digamos este libro de la
amazonía la arqueología de mujer es una
moneda una manera de digamos poner el
reflector sobre un sector de la
población de investigadores como usted
lo dice que pasa normalmente en lo
obscuro que son décadas que son
invisibles si a pesar que en casi el
feminismo es muy fuerte a pesar de eso
se habla más de la arqueología de los
hombres a pesar que a la origen de la
arqueología amazónica fueron dos
burgueses víctimas norteamericanas bits
y medios y anna woods y desde esa época
hay muchas mujeres y lo interesante son
los temas que abordan que son que no son
temas de masculino ninguna de ella
trabaja sobre la guerra
más bien sobre la comida el arte y es
muy interesante es fascinante de ver no
es por falta de deseo sino por falta de
tiempo que tenemos que exportar aquí en
nuestra misión llegamos ya al final de
esta escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecer a este pan houston- director
de investigación del centro nacional de
investigaciones sociales su presencia en
nuestros estudios gracias a ustedes
hasta muy pronto en otra escala en parís
[Música]